[Music]
the global food system accounts for 34
of greenhouse gas emission at the same
time agriculture is the most affected
sector by climate change climate change
is affecting crop yields
and is making small farmers more
vulnerable so it is not a sector that
can be ignored when talking about
climate change
350 billion dollar of investments
are required annually to transform the
food and agriculture sector
to become greener and more resilient
so far
about 30 percent of our agribusiness
projects have had climate finance
components we plan to increase this
proportion to 50 by 2025 and 75 by 2030.
many climate-related investments are not
immediately obvious from a commercial
perspective private sector clients need
to be nudged into making these
investments for example we are going to
use blended finance to help the coffee
company performing invest most of solar
systems the second challenge is that
many clients do not understand their
carbon footprint and the climate risks
in their business and in their supply
chain we have seen some clients
starting a carbon inventory or a climate
risk vulnerability assessment but this
is still new and adb will need to help
many clients for example by providing
project preparation technical assistance
the third challenge is the fragmentation
of the supply chain small older farmers
dominate agriculture in asia and the
pacific
they are 420 million small farmers with
an average land holding of half a
hectare it means that farmers are
extremely vulnerable to climate risks
and other shocks like
the covenant pandemic it also means that
those farmers are extremely hard to
reach even for governments and this is
where agri-business investment combined
with technical assistance is a very
powerful tool to help those farmers
become greener and more resilient
the most effective way to increase the
sustainability and the resilience of the
food system
is really to consider farmers as
businesses and make investment in both
their physical capital and their human
capital
[Music]
you